what do you
make of david's favorite sighting of the
tic tac
ufo and other pilots who have uh seen
these objects that seem to defy the laws
of physics
well i think you have to take them at
their word
um are they fascinating to you oh
absolutely no i know i know a lot of
these people right so i
i know lou elizando chris mellon
the whole crowd i've been i i saw the
videos
about three weeks or so before
they went public
i was um at a bar with lou
overlooking the pentagon
um in crystal city and they showed them
to me and my hair stood on end and he
said he said this is he said this is
coming out soon and i
i know
one of the guys on the inside who was
the naval intelligence who had
interviewed all of these pilots again
before this came out and it was
hair-raising
to hear this uh but also
exciting
that you know here's not just people's
testimony these are credible individuals
and if you've seen the 60-minute episode
with uh some of the pilots
uh you know they have no monetary gain
if anything they've got negative
gain uh from coming out but then you
also have all of the simultaneous uh
ship analysis from the uss princeton and
the radar analysis etc
so um
you know at the end of the day
it's
just data
it's not a conclusion
um i'm i'd be perfectly happy
honestly perfectly happy if somebody
showed that it was all a hoax
can i go back to my day job
right that could be a hoax but other
things might not be i mean right this is
the point i mean what this is why it's
nice to remove
some of the stigma about this topic
because it's all just data and
and
anomalous events
are such that there's going to be
they're going to be rare in terms of how
much data they represent but we have to
consider the full range of data to
discover the things that actually
represent something that's um if we pull
at it we'll discover something that's
extraterrestrial or something
deep about the phenomena on earth that
we don't yet understand right well if it
only stimulates people for instance to
think okay well what happens if we could
move like that with momentum-less
movement
and
and it stimulates
young individuals to go into the
sciences
to
ask those questions that to me is
fascinating i mean after i've been
openly talking about this in the last
year especially
i've had a number of uh
students from
top schools who aren't my students come
to me and say
if i can help
let me how can i help i never had
thought about this before but you opened
you and others not just you and others
have opened my mind to thinking about
this matter yeah that's why it's
actually funny that uh
elon musk doesn't think too much about
this
these kinds of propulsion systems that
could defy the laws of physics as we
currently understand them
to me
it's a powerful way to think what what
is possible
it's uh it's inspiring even if somebody
doesn't represent uh
extraterrestrial vehicles i think the
the observation itself it's like uh
something you mentioned
which is uh you know hypothesizing
imagining
these things
considering the possibility of these
things
i think opens up your mind
in a way that um
ultimately can create the technology
first you have to believe the
technologies possible before you can
create it right
in my own lab you know we always look
for as i've said before what is
inevitable
and you know saying inevitably this is
the kind of data we need but if we need
that kind of data the instrument we want
isn't
doesn't exist
okay so i imagine the perfect instrument
i can't make it
and you back
into something which is practical and
then you in a sense reverse engineer the
future
of what it is that you want to make
and i've started and sold like
at least half a dozen or more companies
using that basic premise
and so
it was always something that didn't
exist today but we imagined what we
wanted
and at the time many people said it
couldn't be done i mean for instance all
the gene therapy that's done today with
retroviruses
came from
a group meeting in david baltimore's lab
i was a postdoc with him and one of the
other postdocs
wasn't able to you make retroviruses in
a way that he wanted to and i realized i
had a cell line that would allow us to
make retroviruses in two days rather
than two months
and so he and i then worked together to
make that system and now all gene
therapy with retroviruses is done using
this basic approach around the whole
world because something couldn't be done
and we wanted to do it better
and we imagined the future and so that's
i think
what the whole ufo phenomenon is doing
for people it's like well let's imagine
a future
where these kinds of technologies are
but also let's imagine a future where we
don't blow ourselves up right so if
these things are there they manage to
not blow themselves up
so it means that at least
one other civilization got past the
inflection point
you